car shows are back and driving in new
directions
they feature the latest models with
wheels and
heels and new destinations for cars
and the auto shows themselves it feels
different
but we always thought we'd be able to
get something open
but there were some days where we had
some questions about it
first to get approval from the
city and the state and then to make sure
the automakers were on board
but here we are the shows are more
streamlined
more focused on electric cars and after
the pandemic moved many from winter to
summer
they are increasingly moving outdoors
behind us is our bronco mountain this is
a part of our built wild experience
where we're featuring all of our broncos
two-door four-door as well as our bronco
sport this
batman pajama goes 38 degrees incline
and decline outdoor tracks give car
makers a chance to showcase off-road
adventures
the chicago auto show in february 2020
was one of the last before the
coronavirus
shut shows down and it's one of the
first to open back
up this week within weeks it will be
followed by shows in london detroit
new york and los angeles car shows are
increasingly shifting toward electric
cars
like the new kia ev6 when the history
books are written
10 years from now about this period in
the auto industry
this is the time when the transition
happened when the light switch the
electric switch was thrown
increasingly cars aren't gassing up
they're plugging in
fully electric cars like the new 2022
ford f-150
lightning pickup don't have internal
combustion engines so these days
there's a lot more room up front
after the media preview shows like
chicago's face a potential speed bump
when the public is invited in for the
first time since the pandemic hit
will they pull in and see john hendren
al jazeera chicago